bu film hoşgeldin hoşbulduk teşekkür Ne
haber nasılsın iyi misin nasılsınız
İyiyim ben de arkadaşlar da gelmiş
beraber gelmişsiniz şimdi sevincim
robotlardan çok bahsedeceğiz zaten Ama
ben biraz daha başka bir yerden başlamak
istiyorum Çünkü ben biliyorum ki sen
Hayvanları çok seviyorsun ve senin bir
hikayem var köpeğin korsanla ilgili onu
size anlatmak ister misin tabi ve
hayatım boyunca Sen köpeğin korsan
olmuştur ve doğduğumdan beri oradaydı
Onu çok seviyordum birlikte oyun
oynardık yani sohbete gidip karşıma
çıkardı onunla bayağı bir başımız belaya
girmiştir ve aynı zamanda tek onu değil
bütün köpekleri ve kedi hayvanları
sevmem öğretti şu anda feneryolu'nda iki
tane Sokak köpeğim var ve bir tanesi var
kedim var
bu isimlerini cevap ver ubico dilinden
alıyorlar aynı zamanda bir tane Ali
Nazik diye bir köpeğimiz var çünkü çok
nazik yemek yiyor ve evdeki Kardeşim
böyle anda çok seviyorum ve robotların
için ölçü alırken çok bana yardımcı
oluyor hayvan sever olmanın kötü yanında
Basic içindeyken Köpeğim korsan
kaybettim ve çok üzüldüm böyle evden bir
anda Kuşlar çıkacakmış bir yerde ama
çıkmadı ve bana en çok sorulan
sorulardan biri Büyüyünce ne olmak
istediğinde veteriner diyordum isteğinde
daha da artmıştı Saki iki sınıfta bir
matematik projesi yapmam gerekiyordu
uzunluk ölçüleri ile ilgili ve bir yere
gitmem gerekiyordu O yüzden Yoldayken
Rüzgar değirmenleri gördük ve bunların
kağıtları vardı bir tür da
bu ve Bunlar Uçak kalktı kadar büyüktü
ve ne olduklarını merak ettim Anneme
sordum bana dedi ki projenin Bununla
ilgili yaparsan hem eğlenceli olur hem
de soruların cevaplarını bulursun o
yüzden hemen bir hafta içinde bir tane
röportaj hazırladık bu makine mühendisi
arkadaşı Egemen Sultan ile ve makinesi
ne yaptın Araştırdım ve ilk defa robot
kelimesiyle orada tanıştım ve elime bir
kalem ve kağıt altın ve bu robotu
çizmeye başladım röportaj bittikten
sonra bu çizimi gösterdim ve bana
Kadıköy'den parçalar olabileceğimi ve
kodlama öğrenmem gerektiğini söyledi
aynı zamanda bir Mekatronik Mühendisliği
aldı bit meslekten bahsettim bu mesleği
Araştırdım ve mekanik kodlama ve
elektronik birleştiren bir mühendislik
dalı olduğunu öğrendim büyüyünce emayti
ve estağfur Üniversitesi'nde ya pay zeka
ve makine öğrenmesi üzerinde eğitim
almak istiyorum Peki o zaman senin
tercihin Meslek tercihi bir anda
veterinerli
O patron üye kaydı ama her şeyi merak
ediyorum senin Sen kodlamayı nasıl
öğrendin Ben Minecraft soymayı çok
seviyordum nasıl yapıldığını merak ettim
İnternetten araştırdım ve yapmak bana
imkansız gibi geldi ta ki dördüncü
sınıfta bir tane İngilizce öğretmenimiz
dersimiz eğlenceli yapabilmek için bize
bir oyun yapıyordu ve ona nasıl
yaptığını sordum ve bana e makinesi kaç
programı söyledi ve bu yapabilirsin
eminim iki çok kolay çünkü dedi ve bu
kelime Bence sallandırdı Buradan seni
cesaretlendiren hem de dersleri
renklendiren sevgili öğretmenine
sevgilerimizi yollayalım bizlere değil
mi peki sonra sen bir oyun tasarladığın
birisini ve hediye olarak bana
yapabilirsin Kendisi çok sihirli
geliyordu ve hala da gelmeye devam
ediyor Kendime bunu söylüyorum ve bu
bunu birisi söylesin de daha güzel
geliyor ve ay
bu anlattığım ve bana yılbaşında
çocuklar için kıskançlık kodlama kitabı
aldılar ve bu kitaptan ben internetten
kullanmaya başladım ve öğrendikten sonra
ilk oyunumuz dedemin 70. yaş doğum günü
için yaptım listeden de burada Peki
şimdi ben bir şey daha merak ediyorum
kodlamayı Tamam öğrendi Well As tekrar
korsana geri dönecek olursam bir ki bu
robotik kısmına geçiş nasıl oldu
hayallerini gerçekleştirmek için artık
böyle foca yapıyordum ve aynı zamanda
projeleri yaparken Maker hareketiyle
hareketini öğrendim ve mekik hareketi
tüketmekten s üretmeye yönelik bir
hareket ve ve geri dönüşüm fikirleri bu
hareketten esinlendi
bu ve mutfak aletleri çok özel bir ilgim
var peki ailen boyayiniz karşılıyor
robotlarından birinin kafası salata kabı
Hatta burada görebilirsiniz öbür de
bozuk olduğunu öldürdüm ve annemin hala
inatlı bulduk olmadığını söylediği tost
makinesi ve en önemlisi robotumun
bacakları onları da babam biraz
tembellik yaptı aşağı geç indi ve bu
yüzden de çöplerle rakip pazarlık yapmak
zorunda kaldı biraz erken inseydi
parasız olacaktı geç kaldı Üstüne para
ödedim olan öyle mi Aynen Sırdar Peki
sevincim şunu da merak ediyorum yani
senin gibi Çocuklar nasıl çalışıyorlar
çevrende Mesela kim var senin gibi
arkadaşlarım var mı kimlerde böyle bilgi
alışverişinde bulunuyorsun hayatının
farklı zamanlarda farklı insanlar
oluyordu ama hiç değişmeyen Annemle
babam ben bir
o ilk başladığımız zaman çok yanlış
hissetmiştim gitmek istemiyordum ama
annemin ilgilerin cinsiyetli olmadığını
söylemesi farkında değil Yanımda
yürümesi beni cesaretlendirdi ayrıca
teknik anlamda da meteorların oldu ve bu
meteorlarla gittiğim zaman birşeyde
girmem gerekiyor ve Çünkü bana direkt
cevap söylemiyorlar onun yerine birlikte
araştırıyoruz birlikte öğreniyoruz aynı
zamanda Babam da bana kendi kendine sor
demişti Ve bu şekilde araştırıyorum
Ben kendi kendime soru soruyorum problem
çıktığı zaman sonra bunu araştırıyorum
peki gene çevrendeki arkadaşlara şöyle
baktığımızda bana birazcık böyle yani
Çok da fazla kız arkadaşım yok benimle
bu heyecanı paylaşan diye sık atmıştım
diye hatırlıyor musun Neden sence böyle
silin yurt dışında çok fazla kolona ile
ilgili topluluklar var Özellikle
bunların en önemli örneklerinden biri
irlanda'da 2011 yılında kurulan Kordon
Joker dojo çocuklara hiçbir Maddi değer
ödemeden
bu gören çocuklara kodlama öğreten bir
yer ve bu korkutucu aynı zamanda rastro
pay ile birlikte T her sene kul projesi
yarışmasını yapıyor ve bu irlanda'da
olabiliyor Amerikalı veya İngiltere da
ama bunu yarışmamız bu ne kadar yarışma
de setler bile aslında çocukların
projelerine ilham almak ve ilham vermek
veya iyi fikirler almak ve projelerini
hayata geçirmek için güzel bir yer ve bu
yarışmada şu robotumuz bozulursa hemen
yardıma koşuyorlar Mesela benim tost
makine kafalı robotun bozulmuştu burada
ve hemen yanıma koşup yardıma koştular
ve aynı zamanda burada bir İtalya'dan
bir arkadaşımla tanıştım ve şu anda
onunla Fikir alışverişi yapıyoruz ve
projeleri problemlerimizi birlikte
çözüyoruz ancak
mı sizde bu topluluklar çok fazla yok ve
etkinliklerde öbür ülkelere göre
karşılaştırdık larımız damak oldukça az
topluluklara sayısının az olduğunu
söyledi ama coderdojo ile ilgili
söylediğim bir şey daha aklıma takıldı
Dedim ki hani hiç bir çocuğun maddi bir
katkı beklenmeden bu becerilerini
geliştirmeleri için yapılmış şimdi bu
işler pahalı işler mi Selin ne diyorsun
Benim yaşındaki çocukların en iyi
öğrenme yöntemi Hani hayallerini
gerçekleştirmek ve buna da deneme ve
yanılma dinle biliyor tabi deneme
yanılma yaparken en iyisi bir ailemizden
birisinin olması Yoksa tek özellik
tehlikeli işlerde olacak yoksa bir şey
patlayabilir ve aynı zamanda bir şey
patladı zaman Bunlar çöpe gidebiliyor o
yüzden yurtdışındaki parçalar çok
ucuzken Türkiye'de çok pahalı oluyorlar
ve bana yurt dışında sponsoru olup
olmadığını soruyorlar yoktu dinozor çok
şaşırıyorlar Çünkü yurtdışındaki
projeler birey
her yerde özellikle kızların yaptığı
polislerde destek ve eğitim çok fazla
oluyor Ha evet buradan parça
üreticilerine de ve saçlarınızı
göndermiş olalım bu vesileyle değil mi
şimdi sen biraz önce bir şey söyledin
babam bana güzel bir şey söyle dedi ne
söylemişti Kendi kendine soru sormayı
öğren hatta biraz önce Caner Hoca'nın
konuşmasında dinlemişti kandırdı bana
gelmeyin ben size masa yaptım araştırma
masası herkes gelsin buradan araştırsın
ve de mm 25'in en önemli becerileri
açıklandı Geçenlerde senin seninle
konuşmuştuk hatırlarsa onlardan bir
tanesi de kendi kendine öğrenme becerisi
ay şimdiden geliştirmiş sen onu
Tebrikler bir ki şimdi ben gene şu
koysana geri döneceğim Çünkü oradan
aldığım ilhamla çok güzel bir şey
yarattın Sen Ice Tea For You hikayesini
dinleyelim mi Ben köpeklere bayılıyorum
Biraz önce bahsettiğim gibi sokakta
gördüm ama aa köpek değil zıplıyorum
hatta
bu bastırıyorum ve yurt dışındayken Ben
bir görme engelli kişilere Par köpeğini
gördüm ve düşündüm ki eğer ben korsanı
kaybedince çok üzüldüysen ames görme
engelli kişi göbeğini kaybettiği zaman
hem dostu hem de tekrar gözünü kaybetmiş
olur diye düşünüp ip for yapmaya karar
verdim Ayşe'yi folyoyu yapmadan önce
İngiltere ve Amerika'daki rehber köpek
derneklerini ara soru sordum ve bunların
cevaplarına göre de robotun planlamaya
başladım görme engelli kişilerin
telefonlarını özel bir uygulama ile
kontrol edebildikleri öğrendim ve bunun
için bir hemen uygulama tasarlamaya
başladım ki ip folyoya iletişime
geçebilirsin ler bu şekilde görme
engelli kişi Ay sephoraya belirli
konutlar verebiliyor Bir de telefonun
şarjı biterse benim çok oluyor mesela
köpeğe bir tane tasma sardım üç tane
düğüm ekledim Bunlar da ileri geri ve
dur Eğer bu
bu engelli kişinin telefonu şarj biterse
direk bu tasma kontrol edebilirler ve şu
andaki gördüğünüz yeni versiyonu ve bu
sefer telefonu kullanmak yerine direkt
Onu kontrol edebiliyorsunuz Ayrıca
görmen gel ki robotla sohbet edebiliyor
ve ayrıca otunun navigasyon Üzerinde
çalışıyorum süper Sandero çalmasınlar
diye çalıştırmıyoruz onları bugün peki
bir robotun daha vardı senin selincim
galiba şu an burada değil ama okul için
tasarladığın eğer gizli değilse
bilgileri biraz paylaşabilir misin
buradan tabip robotun biri Follow okulda
öğrencilere idare ve öğretmenlere
yardımcı olabilecek robot ve bir proje
üzerinde yüz tırnak ve görüntü işleme
özelliklerine de sahip
bir deli Follow öğrencilerin yüzden
tanıyarak isimleriyle hitap ederek
selamlıyor onlar ciltte onları nasıl
bulduklarını soruyor dialog sol
sayesinde ve cevaplarına göre yapay
zekalı onları ayrı nasıl onlara bir tane
öneri verebiliyor Ayrıca Google'a
sistina pis sayesinde öğrenci robota
bilgi sorabiliyor
bu Eğer yapılması gereken duyuru varsa
bu duyuruları yapıyor ve öğretmenler son
anda ödev vermeyi çok sevdiği için bu
ödevleri öğrencilere ulaştırıyor ve
ayrıca bir from en önemli
özelliklerinden biri zorbalığı
engellemeye çalışması bunun için ve her
öğrenci Bir tane saat tasarladım Bu
saatin üzerinde bir tane nabız sensörü
ve ve panik düğmesi var Eğer öğrenci
Korkusuz al panik düğmesine basıp arsa
ve anladık sensörü bir artık bunda bir
artış hissederse hemen geç o ile Ay bir
kaynakçı oluyor ve genç sayılar
sayesinde öğrencinin yerini bulup ona
gidiyor ses kayıt sistemi ve gölge
işlemi sistem olduğu için oldukça
Ciğerci etkisi olacağını düşünüyorum
O senin müthiş bir robot olacak gibi
görünüyor Bu Her şey bitince değil mi
şimdi bir şey soracağım sana gerçekten
beni nefessiz dinliyorum seni ya senin
bu dünyaya geliş Amacın ne olabilir
acaba henüz Ondört yaşındaki da
keşfedecek çok zamanı var ama insanları
teknolojiyi iyilikten size daha çok
kötüye kullandığını ve insanların
ilgisini bu şekilde çektiğini görüyorum
bence teknoloji iyilik için kullanılmalı
ve bunun içinde oldukça geniş falan var
bence çocukla bu geniş alanları
doldurabilir ve teknolojiyi
kullanılabilir ama bunu yaparken Engine
hangi cinsiyetten geldi önemli değil ama
fırsat eşitliği şart sevince şimdi seni
burada anneler izliyor babalar izliyor
ekranları başında seni yaşında
arkadaşlarını izliyor son olarak onlara
neler söylemek istersin gelseydi şöyle
alalım bir son sözlerini duyalım ne
olursa olsun hayallerinizden vazgeçmeyin
ve
Siz devam edin kim ve çocukları çok
fazla Sen Küçüksün işte beceremezsin
gibi özellik bazı alanlarda kız
çocuklarına daha çok söylendim duyuyorum
bunları dinlemesin ler diyerek devam
etsinler ve aile söylemek istediğim şey
de şu bütün çocuklarına eşit
davransınlar fırsat eşitliği versinler
ve çocukların düşüncelerine ve
fikirlerine saygı duysunlar Bence
eşitlik ve iyilik bulaşıcı ve evde
başlarsa bütün dünyaya yayılır broo